hey folks
we are back with the 20 second
dark horse podcast live stream the q a
section
we are joined through a feat of well
yes duct tape and baling wire but we ran
out of duct tape so it's almost
entirely baling wire that we are using
we have
eric r weinstein phd on the phone
ready to join us he is uh it turns out
this will surprise
none of his followers he is not shutting
down stem
isn't that right eric that's true in
fact
my problem with the duct tape is that
the feathers keep sticking
ah terrible this this is this is why
people confuse the two of you
yes right there yeah this is why i don't
want them to
yeah all right so be with you in
uh performatively in order to protest
the stupidity of the moment
researching performatively yes yes yes
excellently excellent uh so what do we
do
people are cow towing to the maoism
well my feeling is is that they may be
smarter than us because
at some level we may be in the process
of outsmarting ourselves given how
stupid this moment is
and it's really remarkable to to me
that if you know as i've said before if
you had a movement called
save the ba adorable baby penguins from
hunger
no matter what the movement stood for
you would have a lot of people who would
sign on because they want to communicate
just how
beautiful and decent they are dude i
didn't know there was such a movement
i'm making a mental note
right now to go sign up for it as soon
as this is done
you heard it here well i guess you heard
it here second right save the baby
penguins from hunger there it is
adorable baby i should have put in the
word adorable heather thank you for
bringing that up i also should say
somebody left a comment uh recently on
one of my videos which i quite liked
which was
we all see the cheese some of us see the
trap
that's sweet it's very good that's sweet
that is very good
yeah we all see the trees some of us see
the trap that's that's very well
i wish i wish i wish it were mine i
agree
i saw somebody referring to an outbreak
of anti-semitism
which i thought was a very good turn of
phrase
for what is sure what is happening
all right so uh what else can you tell
us what are we missing about
this moment well i think that the key
issue is is that some concept of wronged
is substituting for some concept
of um correct so the more wronged you
can
claim to have been the more correct
um you have to be because no one is
allowed to challenge you the act of
challenging a person who claims to have
been wronged
with an intersectional claim on that on
that issue of oppression
is a person who cannot be disputed and
so the issue of if i have
less intersectional and you are more
more intersectional
as per the uh concept of oppression
then effectively i can't be right and
tell you that you're wrong and therefore
i have to cheat you
of reasonable feedback and this is where
lived experience
and claims of identity are used also to
game the system because
not only does your does your position in
the progressive stack how many
intersectional points you have
contribute to how wrong you can claim to
be but it's only you who gets to do the
math on how wronged you are
uh i wish it were that simple heather i
just don't think it is
because i think that one of the problems
that you have to deal with
is that the underlying idea is that my
history of being wronged
has to do with my history of being
able to succeed within a system
and the problem of let's say the
overseas chinese or the jews
is that you have people who are often
oppressed
but who are often very successful well
wronged
and the biggest problem here
is that for example the jewish claim
on having been wronged
is particularly problematic for this
movement
because it rivals or even can exceed
the black claim and therefore the claim
must be disposed of
with extreme prejudice because it gives
the lie
to the idea that one's level of
oppression and one's
uh ability to to sort of navigate the
system
um the assumed linkage is called into
question
yeah i think i i don't go on
one more let me give another example of
the kind of reasoning one may not
introduce are you familiar with the
killing of daniel
shaver in 2016 no
daniel shaver was um
in a motel i think in
arizona and he had some kind of a gun
for pest control i think a pellet gun
that had been seen in a window
and the police showed up and they forced
him
prostrate into the hallway and they gave
very complicated instructions for what
he was to do if he didn't want to be
killed on the spot
and having some alcohol in his system he
was unable to follow the instructions
and was shot five times i think died
instantly
if you imagine that george floyd
who was by all turns uh somebody who did
not
necessarily believe that black lives
matter because he i think he was present
in a home invasion into a pregnant black
woman's house
previously served five years for letting
a bunch of armed men
into the house while he pointed a gun at
this woman if i understand correctly
you have a situation whereby were the
two killings exchanged
i have no question that black lives
matter would be enraged by the killing
in arizona and relatively mute on the
killing in
minneapolis and so what we're talking
about is we're talking about a level of
clairvoyance
of um a right to infer
the belief that no white person fears
the police
this is only understandable by black
people
the entire concept is beyond
preposterous
but it plays into a sense that i think
white people and others who do not have
many black friends
are incredibly frightened of this and i
think those of us who do have black
friends and strong black contacts are
completely confused
because many of them are saying what the
apps yeah in fact
i had forgotten the the young man's name
who was shot
but he is obviously in this clip
quite terrified that he is about to be
shot he's trying
he's pleading for them not to shoot him
and i think he
his shorts he adjusted his shorts as he
was trying to comply with
uh the orders and was shot so the point
is the fear is obviously there despite
the fact
that he's a white guy facing heavily
armed cops etc you're right it is it is
a
a very um interesting counterpoint
and i think i mean the shutdown stem
idea is about shutting down
the tools with which to test whether a
claim
is true and the problem is what they
leave
is how intuitive a claim is and in fact
what we are watching
is claims that are not true being
converted into intuitive claims by force
right in other words by the threat of
contradicting them
resulting in you being punished people
are are convincing them this is like a
group rationalization
that we are watching unfold well you say
group i would say cult
i mean i think what you're what you're
seeing is you're seeing an ideology
occupying uh a place in the human mind
where the you know there's probably like
a chomsky and like
pre-grammar for religion many people
don't have a religion
this is clearly inhabiting that place
where you have a closed circle of ideas
which is a
sort of a sealed epistemology and
science is the same threat to this
that it is to um claims of the catholic
church about
you know if there's a miracle where milk
is coming from the eyes of a statue
um you know more or less
we have a lot of sensors and detectors
we can probably tell through inspection
if a miracle is occurring and this is a
miracle in the same
sense that that is a miracle which is
it's not true
so the point well the point i was making
earlier i don't think is a simpler
version of this but actually an adjacent
point
which is that people who don't rise in
the progressive stack because they don't
have any intersectional points because
their lineage or their sex doesn't have
a history of oppression
there are claims that can be made now to
game the system
and this is what we're seeing with the
with the trans ideology and again this
is not to say that trans isn't real and
rare
i want us to stop constantly saying this
is not to say no of course
well but it but it's but it's important
right i mean i actually so this this is
this is one point where brett and i do
do this thing um because
we actually do know trans people and you
know most people don't actually
right we actually had trans students who
we don't talk about because their
privacy is paramount um
and you know who who we understand to be
really and truly
trans and to to not be out on the
streets talking about how trans they are
because
um they live in this deeply horrifying
position
of having their actual biological sex be
out of step deeply out of step
with what their brains are telling them
about what their sex is so that that is
a real
but super rare phenomenon so i i will i
will do it in this case eric just
because i because most people watching
probably don't know any trans people and
it's really easy to dismiss the trans
rights activism as entirely
insane yeah but let's let's also
consider a blanket statement which is
of course i don't mean the ostensible
thing x that i will be in the future
miss portrayed as believing and i would
like to have a
general statement that anybody who's put
as many hours into the world as i have
uh this is like the jizya in islam where
you have to pay a constant tax at a
higher rate
than anyone else and effectively what
they do is they grind you into a pulp
so what i would say is i don't believe
that this is actually as opaque as we're
pretending it is
the idea that this is um
you know a highly politicized
demonstration of power
uh i think is evident to everyone
whether or not we echo it is a different
question
but um i can tell you if you want to
know
uh that the federal government through
the national science foundation and the
national academy of sciences
studied the fact that a tight labor
market would bring women and minorities
into science
and decided that it was far too
expensive
both in terms of a fear that the quality
would be lower
and that the price would be too high so
they opted for a program
to fake a labor shortage in the 1980s
which is of course impossible in a
capitalist economy
because the wage rate rises to whatever
the correct level of need is
and if these people were all interested
in
the blackening the feminization
the transification whatever you want to
call it of science
the best things they could do would be
to put in term limits when they got rid
of
mandatory retirement for these positions
they would cut down the visa programs
which of course
they don't want to do because it saves
them a ton of money china gets what it
wants which is
access to all of our labs we get what
the professors want which is cheap labor
and this whole thing
survives only by virtue of the fact that
there are no grown-ups
anywhere in the sense making apparatus
that the new york times washington post
and npr used to represent
so that everybody who wants to tune into
reality has to tune into
um you know a bunch of uh kids with
their teenagers doing the audio and
visuals
yeah but they'll work i think you're i
think you're you're missing something
important and
i think it has to do with uh why heather
and i
tend to be very careful about saying
these
preambles and saying you know that their
content is
careful it's not a don't hurt me thing
we've already paid the price
right they can't hurt us in a sense
we've already we've already been through
it
but there is a
question the paradox that is being
deployed
is putting people who are facing
something opportunity not being equally
distributed
or whatever it is that results in
um there being some population is not
being represented in some fields at a
high enough level there's a question
who is really actually advocating for
your interest and your point about
jews having faced a uh obviously
appalling history of oppression
and yet being successful really points
to the answer
the enlightenment was not a jewish
project the tools
are not resident in some particular race
they
are absolutely democratizable and the
thing that empowers people
is science so to the extent that you're
actually interested
in taking a population that actually did
face a
unique kind of oppression especially in
the new world
and empowering them the obvious tool is
science
and for these cynical forces to be
prying these populations away from
science and telling
what they've done is they've taken the
antidote and they've labeled it as a
poison which we've seen in other
contexts so
it is necessary it is necessary to put
that message into the world
actually i think i've gone to a much
more
uh pointed perspective let me let me
just share it with you i don't know
whether you saw my walk and talk on this
but the um my feeling is when i started
here
hearing abolish the police and i think
about
the threats to jewish schools
and places of worship for example
my feeling is i've had it with you
right i want to be very clear and
adamant
you are overstepping your bounds whoever
you
are as to what you are advocating for
because maybe you feel in some way that
you will be marginally safer and
boy do i not believe that uh black
families would be safe for the world
without the police but
um you have no right to endanger
everyone else
pretending that everything is about you
and
the thing that i want to get very
clearly across
is we had a world in which covid
created tremendous unemployment it
created tremendous
need to see other people because we are
social creatures
we are all pissed off we are everybody
are you guys there sorry i just lost you
for one second um
we are all in a situation where
everybody was
amped up and i don't know if you
remember did you remember the film
animal house
of course there's a scene in the in the
end where there's a parade
and the person leading the parade has a
giant baton he throws it into the air
and one of the animal animal house
members pushes the guy to the ground
grabs the baton and takes the marching
band down a blind alley
and because everyone's playing their
instrument they can't have a
conversation
so they all blindly follow down the
blind alley
and the person represents to me what
black lives matter as an organization
just did with a global anger and
frustration
which is now 100 focused on the issue of
race
not even the issue of race an issue of a
particular race
so we saw in the evergreen run-up to
this
we saw experiments with demonizing
people who weren't white
right asians were singled out as part of
the problem
and offered an opportunity to be
re-educated into the fold
and now what we're seeing is this is
about anti-blackness pure and simple and
everybody else is the problem and you
know it's all predictable
well you know to your point about native
americans obviously have an
astoundingly good claim on oppression
um i i think at some level where we've
gotten to
is that we all feel very uncomfortable
like if you take an ex a person who's
had everything go wrong in their life
every every knock against them has
occurred and you have a second person
born with a platinum spoon in their
mouth right
what we can't allow to derange is that
the level
of badness that one can claim
proxies for having a point and you can't
also then pick and choose
like uh who gets to say who can feel
what oppression i don't
personally believe that anti-semitism
can't be understood by somebody willing
to have an intuition pump put in
i mean having friends who are black and
like being in new york city with my
friend stefan alexander and watching a
cab
that we were trying to take together
slowed down for me and when it saw
stefan
speed away it told me yeah absolutely
i've now been through that
as somebody who you know
is very deep into black american culture
um i can tell you that i got beat up at
our at our high school brett
uh for being what i guess i have to say
an
n-word lover although i guarantee you
they didn't use the genteel euphemism
um many of us have felt enough of this
through our close associations
that i don't think i can grasp the
entire experience
but this claim that nobody can possibly
understand what i've been through
there's a turing test for this and it's
called screenwriting how many
screenplays
have you seen where you accepted that
a you know like you know kung fu panda
was written by jews and china said well
finally somebody understands chinese
culture perfectly why is it in america
this is brilliant there is a turing test
for this and it's called screenwriting i
haven't i haven't heard you say that
before i haven't heard that formulation
before i think that's
that's a perfect encapsulation and it
puts the lie to my lived experience
trumps everything you have to say to me
well you know you just just i guarantee
you
that i could probably write a story
about a
you know a young black kid's first day
in a swanky private school
and um my guess is it would be pretty
credible
yep so um
there's obviously a ton to be done here
uh
this day is obvious this day is
obviously special i'm wondering
um before we uh i wanted to read
something to you guys
and i'm wondering um whether i can do it
on my phone and talk at the same time
give me one second because it came
it came from caltech
um and what it was was absolutely
chilling to me
uh
and if i can just locate it here yes
is this new um it went out to i think
it's kept for caltech alum
it's new it says what we face is the
all-important question
what do we do we are a community that
acts presented with an intellectual
challenge
we would hardly dive in and puzzle it
out
this issue of racism against the black
community in particular
should be no different black lives do
matter now here comes the great part
we must continue to press the sentiment
until there is
no one left who would dispute it or
rationalize it
however well-intentioned the alternate
perspective may be
in brief inaction is not an option as we
are teachers
and our training and education drive us
to tackle complex problems
that most challenge society racism
included
can you imagine a teacher or a
researcher saying
we must continue to press the sentiment
until there is no one left who would
dispute it or rationalize
that's a threat well it's also a
complete
lack of understanding of what science is
can you imagine if no one were allowed
to challenge
whether stress causes ulcers or
the wisdom of the food pyramid or
whether or not
newton's laws could be violated it's a
misunderstanding not just of science but
of education
it is indoctrination not education and
it is anti-science
well uh we were uh i don't know
whether you wait can i just riff one
thing off that heather
maybe the idea is that if we constitute
it like this
then science is anti-blackness
because science is not sitting around
and saying well you have lived
experience
so i guess nobody else can say anything
except the other people who have lived
experience their lived experience
doesn't matter i think one of the very
weird things about this movement
bizarre is the complete deadening of
empathy towards certain groups
including groups that have a history of
higher oppression
yeah no that's that's right it's
dehumanization
of everyone who uh is being we are being
told our other
uh even when we belong to those groups
ourselves and uh
somehow the majority of people
appear to be stepping in line well this
is this is happening
horizontally inside of there is a social
dynamic that includes people with names
and identities
inside each of these organizations that
letter you read is the result
of some discussion that happened
somebody won that discussion and a
letter went out and we will never
see the internal workings we have seen
it at evergreen we were fortunate to
have them
film it and to actually see the inner
workings but
this is a this is a show of force it is
advertising to us that it has the
capacity to take
everything that one might look to for
protection and to invert it
and frankly i'm not convinced that it
doesn't and the question is
how do we bootstrap a response that
functions in other words somehow all of
these major
scientific institutions are tweeting
shutdown stem they've just alerted us to
the plan
some of us have been hearing this for
years so
we have to we have to announce
that there is an alternative and what it
is is it's the real deal
your friends are not the people
who have inverted allyship and turned it
into a subordinate relationship
your friends are the people who
understand that allyship is a peer
relationship
right your friends are not the one with
the simple solutions your friends are
the ones who are telling you something
that some part of you knows which is
that
a deep understanding of science
liberates
it is the antidote to oppression so
i would love it if we could hashtag
something in response to this hashtag
that is taking over
the scientific establishment yes except
i think that to be blunt about it brett
that puts us on a level playing field
and we have the high ground of course i
think it's very important to state very
clearly you know you and i come from a
scientific family
and our grandfather was a chemist
the family do you know about the
brookside plunge
i don't in the 1920s there was a
swimming pool in pasadena and one of the
things that radicalized our family
was that they had a swimming pool that
was
the water was changed once a week and
the day before
the water was changed they allowed
blacks to swim in the pool and they
called it
international day because that way the
whites wouldn't be contaminated by
blackness right and our family
was so sickened by this stuff that we
began
a project which is you know 100 years
old
which has to do with using you know
science and decency
together to eliminate nonsense and
and [ __ ] and
the idea that this is now going to be
inverted
that the very people who have always
been progressive who have always been
um and i don't want to use the word
allyship because it's now so tainted
and contaminated as some subordinate
relationship
um where we are is that we
some of us actually have open
conversations
loving conversations with people who
are all different hughes come from all
over the world all different situations
we feel least guilty i think the great
danger here
is a huge number of people who have no
actual intimacy within other communities
and those people are so moved
because they suspect deeply in their own
hearts that they are really
deeply bigoted i think that the right
you know if you for example are an inter
an interracial relationship with
interracial children
you're probably not all that focused on
the idea that you absolutely hate people
uh secretly who don't look like you so
whenever
this stuff comes around you just sort of
feel sick to your stomach and i think
what we're doing here with stem
is stem is the great refuge
where anybody of merit should be able
to force their ideas down the throat of
the bigot and this was even true in the
soviet union
which um you know had a very competitive
culture i remember i think david kajdan
showed up to the moscow state university
entrance exam with the kippah
and they hated jews they found any
excuse they could to get rid of them
and the guy said sorry i'm coming
through there's nothing you can do about
it i'm that good
and you know i really believe at some
level that what we're talking about
the black community at least the black
community that i grew up knowing
pretty well was the most merit-oriented
community
because what had been used to drive them
out was
trickery you know fake you know poll
taxes or literacy tests and all this
nonsense
and so they developed a fiercely
meritocratic culture
and that's what allowed eminem for
example to win in rap battling maybe
people didn't want him to win but the
fact was he was better
the same thing about open mic night in
harlem
where the jazz people said look whites
are welcome to take the stage but you
don't mind if we blow you off the stage
if you can't play
if you could play you could hang and i
think that the key point is
science is open mic night think of it
as caltech is mittens playhouse and
you've got some of the best people in
the world and man if you can blow your
horn or if you can play the keys
you always should have a place and to
lose that
to a completely different sector of the
black community
which knows not the huge strides that
were made through merit
right being better to be blunt
it's just offensive to 100 years of
black history
uh i agree we're gonna have to go but i
would
say uh can we combine forces
hashtag science liberates and also
hashtag science is open mic night
science is open mic night that's what i
just wrote down no seriously science is
open mic night is the
is the second thing you've said just in
this little conversation eric that
strikes me as
the the gem of truth that no one else is
saying
well i i really appreciate that um i
think that the thing that we have to
recognize though
is that um part of what made open mic
admittance uh such an incredible
meritocratic
uh tradition to to to blow juilliard
let's say out of the water
because of the the hotness of the
improvisation was the fairness of blacks
who associated
star chambers and closed rooms and all
that kind of stuff
with prejudice and bigotry and the idea
that open mic
night was judged fairly if you could
play you could play there was no
escaping it
there's a beautiful photograph called i
think one day in harlem
which ostensibly people remember as
all of the greatest jazz players in one
photo
and they remember it as black because
the word harlem is there
when you look at that photo how many
white faces
latin faces do you see one thing that
you have to just admire
black america for maintaining is that
they were so
pissed off about the anti-marinocratic
methods that were used to keep them down
that they were the most ferocious garden
guardians of pure meritocracy the only
rival i can think of
were certain sort of subcultures within
the soviet union
and i think that what we are talking
about is in fact
anti-black of course it's anti-black
well but but it's anti-black because the
black
cultural trait of saying if a white man
can play the horn
he gets to sit in if he can handle these
time signatures and these weird keys and
these strange modes
he's in he's one of us yeah i mean
this is obviously anti-black i tweeted
that
yesterday about uh shut down stem
and that's the problem is that uh
we've been saying forever that these
syllogisms these false beliefs that are
at the head of this movement
empower the worst people in the
community and place them at the top
because they are willing to take
advantage of this nonsense
and that this is the opposite of
liberation it's going to be
a very short very ugly ride and
there's nothing there's nothing
honorable about it so
hey guys i wanted to just say thanks for
having me on it's a terrible weird
crazy interesting day i don't think
people even understand
what the idea of changing the rules
about
science is and what it means they don't
understand the repercussions
and because it's uncomfortable to say
hey
you you have definite claims on
oppression for sure and you don't have
claims on what you're trying to do now
is such a new message to so many people
the idea that you could say hey you
don't get to do this
saying no just the way you have to say
no to your children if you love them if
you don't love your children
just tell them yes all the time you can
screw them up as badly as you want
but if you want to tell your brother hey
no
you've told me you know brett and i've
told you and so when we use the word
brother do i have black brothers and
sisters or do i not
if i do then no if i don't
then i don't know where we are but i
thought what we wanted
was you wanted complete understanding
and recognition for all of your
accomplishments
which personally i've spent my entire
life in awe of and this feels like a
complete betrayal of everything that
i've studied
in the black community everything that i
love about the black community i just
don't understand this this team's the
height of non-blackness
well it is it is that but as you point
out about the defund the police movement
which is really a shutdown the police
movement uh you don't have the right to
put people in that danger
you may not have the right to put
yourself in that danger but you sure as
hell don't have the right to put anybody
else in that danger but in this case
what we're really talking about as i was
uh i was trying to alert richard dawkins
to what was going on he was not aware of
shut down stem
and i was trying to compel him to this
and and the thing is
what i said to him is this is the
dawning of a new dark age
that's what this is this is the
uninvention of the tool
that brought us out of the darkness and
you don't have a right to do it right
you sure don't have a right to do it
to anybody else um and you're you're a
fool to do it to yourself
all right everybody tune into the dark
horse podcast uh one of the best
podcasts
out there uh it's been an entire i mean
it's been such a privilege to be able to
get in with you guys and hopefully we'll
figure out a way to jack in with
video and this is a little bit rough but
this is a very funny day and the number
of people standing up
is few in number which means that it is
definitely
uh a great time to see who is cowering i
just did a little bit of a poll
uh and i'm going to check in with it i
haven't checked in with it i'm going to
read it to you and i'm going to leave
it says given the following statements
which statement better if imperfectly
represents your view
this moment is genuine this time is
performative
this time is hopeful this moment is
stupid
and the answers are so far
with almost with over 8 000 votes
um this moment is genuine 12 this time
is hopeful 12.2
people are not coming out in the open
and saying what they feel
because they're afraid that they will be
portrayed in ways
that are completely anathema to them
and i have no doubt that we're going to
be portrayed in those ways what i do
know
is that our record is 100 rock solid
over a very long period of time
and that we are in a position therefore
in part because of the investments of
our great grandparents
grandparents and parents of course our
father marched
on washington you know and talks about
that to this day
uh this is a very long process and those
with the credentials to be able to say
this is not in keeping with our best
traditions
need to speak up thank you guys very
much for having me on it's been an
absolute pleasure
thank you awesome we'll talk to you soon
i'm going to advocate we take a quick
break um
and just set up a new link and have this
be a separate
uh separate video okay we got a whole
lot more questions come in
so i'm not gonna be able to go for an
hour solid for here without a break so
let's just take it
two minutes two minutes five minutes um
and we'll be right back
and zach will set up another link sorry
zach i know you didn't see that coming
and we'll be right back
um with the third live stream for today
awesome all right all right see you soon